today on the Matt Walsh show America has
become essentially a collection of
police states where the Bill of Rights
has been effectively nullified and
citizens can get arrested or fined for
engaging in just normal everyday
activities activities that really have
no plausible chance of spreading the
virus anyway but they're still still
getting arrested or fined for it is all
of this worth it for the reward of
safety the possible reward of safety
that we might be getting from it we'll
talk about that also today will cancel
yet again I think for the fourth time
we're gonna cancel
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez for claiming
that the virus is targeting minority
communities because of racism so you
knew that was coming and also I have a
bunch of emails I want to read from
people across the country who've had
run-ins with law enforcement over these
state home orders or people close to
them have had run-ins and and also I've
got a number of emails from police
officers themselves who are not in favor
of having to enforce these ridiculous
laws and have raised some objections of
their own that I think are interesting
and so I want to read those two we'll
get to all of that coming up but before
we do I want to check in with a new
sponsor on the show and you know and I
also want to say just just to begin with
that I really appreciate all the
sponsors and advertisers who support the
show and keep it going this is a
difficult time for for everybody it's
for all companies many of the sponsors
you know we're all sort of struggling to
get through it financially and so I
appreciate you guys supporting the show
and I appreciate you supporting the
sponsors if you can you know if you're
listening to the show and you hear an ad
for a product that you want to buy and
you were thinking of buying anyway and
you have the money and you're able to do
it then then you know I really
appreciate you doing that we're all
trying to get through this together of
course you me all the show's advertisers
and on that note I want to talk to you
about AB sleep you know it's it's it's
really important these days especially
to have a healthy immune system you want
to you know you got to keep your immune
system going and one of the things one
of the best ways to do that is to just
just to get sleep and keep your body
rested and that's why it's time for M AB
sleep is a wearable
solution that fits over the forehead and
gently cools the forehead to reduce
those racing thoughts allowing people
who suffer from sleeplessness to drift
more comfortably into a deeper more
restorative sleep I know that I have
trouble trouble with this myself so I've
found this to be very useful the minds
normal way of dealing with stress and
challenges is to be on guard be more
vigilant and then you start thinking
about there are a lot there's a lot of
things to think about these days and
that's what happens with when we try to
sleep and that's what keeps us up but
brain imaging studies followed by
followed by three 3,800 nights of
clinical studies by renowned sleep
researchers reveal a revolutionary new
way to sleep and actually four out of
five users report getting to sleep
faster with em sleep eff sleep
understands the uncertainty you may be
experiencing at this time it wants to
help so you could save $25 off your
order by using promo code Walsh to save
and continue to try AB risk-free for 60
nights to confirm that it is the
solution you've been looking for and I'm
pretty sure that you'll find that that's
the case go to try Abbott comm slash
Walsh let us help you get sleep you need
and remove the risk from your purchase
that's try Abe dot-com slash Walsh T ry
e BB dot-com slash Wells tribe comm
slash Walsh use promo code Walsh to save
order today with everything going on and
get the sleep you need and deserve
especially these days all right
so on Saturday police in Kansas City
intervened quote-unquote to shut down a
parade of elementary school teachers the
staff of a local school there John Fiske
elementary school decided to organize
the parade just as a way to boost morale
for for the students and to encourage
them in their new distance learning
adventure and all of the the teachers
administrators they you know got
together well then he really get
together they were in their own cars
right and so you would think isolated in
that way you would think that there's
really no chance whatsoever of a virus
being transmitted from car to car but a
spokeswoman for the police later
explained after the illicit gathering
was broken up by the cops that the
celebration of education was not
necessary and was non-essential it was a
non-essential celebration we can't have
any
seneschal celebrations right now two
days before the Kansas City community
was saved from the threat of cheerful
elementary school teachers waving from
their minivans to students
two days before that police in Malibu
arrested a man who was caught
paddleboarding in the ocean now yet it
you got to see that the footage of this
because two boats and three additional
deputies on the shore we're all we're
all we're all brought to the scene to
try to stop this guy from paddle
boarding watch this sheriff's on the
beach
but sure folks coming now might be our
first could this be the first wrath made
for surfing documented on in industry
look now he's trying to bone dude
high-speed pursuit high-speed pursuit
run through the throw the tax down pop
the tires
Oh
[Music]
'sheriff oh yeah now you see that and
you think how could that guy out by
himself in the Pacific possibly contract
or spread the virus how is that gonna
work exactly and when I was talking
about this over the weekend I was told
by people well he's got he's got to get
to the ocean somehow he probably drove
there okay yeah so let me let's let's
just walk through this
he leaves his house walks down his
driveway or whatever he has it gets in
his car so he's isolated in the car
drives down the road gets to a empty
parking lot walks down the beach gets in
the water like at what point through
that whole process is there is there any
plausible possibility that he would
spread or contract the virus well nobody
really knows but orders are orders after
all in fact somebody on Twitter told me
that when I was complaining about this
they said verbatim they said orders are
orders
that's the new American motto forget
about freedom and liberty orders are
orders and so the guy was pulled out of
the ocean and hauled away in handcuffs
not far from that harrowing scene down
down south about two hours I think or an
hour and half maybe the the San Diego
Sheriff's Department was giving out
citations to people who'd committed the
nefarious crime of watching the sunset
on the beach watching the sunset is now
a crime and around the same time over on
the East Coast Pennsylvania State Police
were pulling over and ticketing a woman
who according to the citation was going
for a drive now this was in York County
Pennsylvania and she was going for a
drive in York County Pennsylvania you
may think there that first of all when
you've been locked in your house for
three weeks going for a drive is sort of
an essential activity for your mental
health and you may also think of your
firm if you're familiar with
Pennsylvania York County Pennsylvania
it's a rural area so you'd think a woman
driving along a country road you know
the rural county of York Pennsylvania is
is not really at risk and is not putting
anybody else at risk you'd think that
but none of that matters because the
politicians have spoken and orders our
orders you may leave your home only for
the reasons that they decree a woman in
Minnesota was recently pulled over and
ticketed for two offenses the first was
she was driving on a canceled license
okay that's fair give her a ticket for
that but the second one is she was she
was violating the state's stay at home
orders now what was she doing she went
to Taco Bell and right before that she
had stopped at her storage unit that
she's renting why would one be essential
and now thea there apparently Taco Bell
you're allowed to do you can't go to
your storage unit
there's as far as I know in Minnesota
they don't have anything specifically
written in the law saying you're not
allowed to go to a storage unit and I
can think of many essential reasons for
people to person to go to a storage unit
right but it's just something that I
guess it's up to it's the judgment
called the police officer and he wants
to take it you for he's gonna do it
the point is that you can't just go out
and move around as you please that's the
point what do you think this is a free
country
now officials in other parts of the
nation as we talked about last week have
banned well we know that they've shut
down stores and retailers and everything
but they've also banned essential
retailers from selling non-essential
items like for example mosquito
repellent Jon cardio on Twitter posted
this picture take a look at this CEO
says by order of the of the town they're
not allowed to sell these items look up
the items that they're novelette
mosquito repellent now I would think
mosquito repellent is pretty damn
essential prevents West Nile prevents
malaria I would think that's an
essential activity but apparently we can
only fight one disease at a time we're
focusing on corona virus not those other
diseases so forget well let those
diseases come come do do whatever they
want to do what we're focused on
coronavirus right now the mayor of Port
Isabel Texas has decided for whatever
reason that residents may not travel
with more than two people in their
vehicle and this I've been told by
people around the country this is a this
is a somewhat common regulation now that
you're being told
not only where you can go in your car
but how many people are allowed to be in
your car when you're going there now
once again if you all live in the same
house and you're a family okay you're
already exposed to each other in a house
so why can't you be exposed to each
other in a car what's the difference and
what if you're a single parent with
three kids well I guess - your kids are
at a lock you can only bring one kid if
you got to go to the store or stay home
and starve you know that's your other
choice now how exactly are they going to
enforce this that's that's not exactly
sure but I know that some states have
made that enforcement part easier on
themselves by setting up checkpoints to
stop in question every car that passes
through a person from New York who gets
caught in Florida right now for example
may face sixty days in jail now I want
to remind you here that Florida and New
York are states in America they are not
places in Soviet Russia despite how it
may sound meanwhile protesters outside
of abortion clinics in California and
North Carolina other places as well have
been arrested for violating their
state's state home orders despite the
fact that they were following the
protocols of social distancing so this
wasn't a whole group of people all
bunched up together they were spaced out
like you're supposed to be for social
distancing but doesn't matter you would
think you know you'd think that that
would protect them also there is the the
that obscured legal artifact known as
the First Amendment's that you think
also would protect them but no not that
not that either
the First Amendment has been officially
neutralized as the multiple pastors
who've been arrested for for holding
worship services have also found out now
all of this may seem quite oppressive
and Gestapo ish but a police chief in
Colorado put those worries to the side
if you think that this is oppressive he
said it's not oppressive he explained
that leaving your house and going
outside and doing things is not a right
but a privilege it's a privilege and it
can be revoked if it's misused there was
a prosecutor in Ohio who kind of
exploded in a fit of rage during an
interview over the weekend and he said
that those who
I his state homeowners or his State
State homeowners are committing
felonious assault right so if you if you
like go to the beach or something
against your state you're committing
assault assault against who I don't know
and if you're guilty of that to quote
him directly who said you can sit your
butt in jail sit there and kill yourself
again I remind you this is the United
States of America or at least it used to
be now apologists for our newly
established police state will tell me
that states and localities have the
authority to impose restrictions in an
emergency and that's true but the
question of how far their authority
actually goes is already complicated and
in this case it's made even more
complicated by the fact that these state
homeowners in many cases are based not
on a current medical emergency in the
respective state but on models that
forecast the possibility of an emergency
in the future
Minnesota is under a state home order
despite having only 29 coronavirus
deaths up to this point in a population
of over 5 million now perhaps the
situation will get worse perhaps it
won't the point is that there is no
current emergency in Minnesota or many
of the other states that are on lockdown
there is rather a model that projects in
emergency in the future and if projected
emergencies can justify the effect of
nullification of the Bill of Rights then
where's the limits haven't we now
granted the the government the power to
cease near total control on the basis of
any real or phantom threat has isn't
that what's what's happened here and
there
problems too we don't know that these
lock downs will actually have the effect
of saving lives we don't know that it's
possible as dr. fowey himself has
admitted that the virus will come
roaring back to life anyway whenever we
leave our our houses whenever that
happens to be whether it's a month for
now or six years from now it's also
possible that the illness came to
America back in November or December or
January aboard any any of the an any
number of the hundreds of thousands of
travelers from China who came here
during that span now if that's the case
then it would seem the viral horse left
the Chinese barn a long time ago and
it's way too late to do lock downs and
and that means that we are doing these
lock downs and we're obliterating our
national economy driving millions into
ruin
for no reason in fact all we're doing is
locking people down in their homes
locking people who have been exposed in
their homes with people who had not to
that point been exposed so what do we
have then we have a series of indefinite
state home orders based on dubious
models and dubious projections with a
dubious chance of success and which
often outlaw behavior that could not
even plausibly put anyone at risk from
the disease that may or may not or maybe
already has become epidemic in the
states where these laws have been
enacted is that good enough to justify
treating Americans like their subjects
in a communist dictatorship is it good
enough I would argue that nothing could
ever justify a lot of what we're seeing
here the 1st and 4th amendments which
are the provisions of the Bill of Rights
that have really had the worst time of
it recently I would say serve no purpose
and have no reason to exist if they can
be cancelled or overridden whenever the
government might have a specially
compelling reason to do so in fact I
would say it is only when the government
has a specially compelling reason to
override the amendments that the
amendments serve any function after all
we really don't need them we don't need
them during the times when the
government has no interest
infringing on them so if we toss aside
our right to assembly our right to
practice our religion our right to be
free from unreasonable search and
seizure etc whenever the government
insists that such protections are
dangerous and must be tossed aside then
we might as well not have them in the
first place most of the time right the
government would just really doesn't
have any special interest in stopping
you from going out and getting together
and doing what you want to do if we're
saying that only when they have an
interest in doing it can they do it then
okay well then basically they can do it
and then these rights mean nothing it's
kind of like locking a criminal in a
Cell but giving him the key to open it
along with a stern warning to only use
the key if he really really feels like
he has a good reason doesn't the key
make the cell a rather pointless
accessory now sure he might remain in
the cell sometimes but only when he
wants to and it's precisely when he
wants to be behind bars that you don't
really need the bars at all the bars are
only there for the times when he really
desperately wants to get out that's why
you have the bars that he can't get that
he can't escape from I would argue that
the Bill of Rights and the First
Amendment the Fourth Amendment they're
only really there for the times when the
government really really really wishes
they weren't and if in those times we
say okay they're not it's not there you
could pretend it's nothing what's the
point why do we even have it I'm not
suggesting that state governments should
do nothing in response to the
chronovisor I am suggesting that they
shouldn't have the power to do whatever
the hell they want for whatever reason
they want to whatever extent they want
for however long they want with whatever
penalty they want which is what is
happening right now all across the
country government should act justly and
prudently to respond to threats that
endanger citizens lives but there is
little in the way of justice or prudence
or respect for basic human liberties in
these measures that we're seeing all
across the country and that to me is is
the problem
we're gonna get two headlines here in a
second but first all access live want to
remind you again if you haven't tuned in
yet to one of these things and I would
suggest I would suggest 8:00 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific we do them
well I want to say I think we're doing
them every day now certainly most of the
days of the week we're doing them and
you know originally all access live is
gonna be something for our all access
members that we were going to roll out a
couple months from now but we moved it
up and now it's open to all Billy wire
members and we're just doing it as a way
to kind of give us a break from the
isolation it's a really relaxed
conversation and so if you're around
tonight at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific make sure you tune in to all
access live and I think you'll enjoy all
right let's go to headlines number one
here's the headline in Vox it says the
CDC has begun testing blood for immunity
against coronavirus reading out says the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention has begun conducting blood
tests it says will help determine if a
person has been exposed to the corona
virus even without showing symptoms
these serological tests or serous
surveys are different from the nose
swabs used to diagnose active cases of
Cova 19 by analyzing blood researchers
be able to tell if a person develops
certain antibodies in the blood
indicating that they were infected by
the virus and recovered if a person can
be shown to have developed these
protections against against reinfection
they could potentially reenter society
now and then it says that they've
already started testing well let's see
here who are they gonna test they're
gonna roll out these surveys in three
phases peep in the here are the three
phases of the three groups that will get
tested people living in hot spots of the
disease such as New York and Seattle but
who were not diagnosed a then a
representative sample of people living
across the country and then and then
health care workers now the survey says
that they've already started testing
some of the people that live in these
hot spots but the the tests of people
who live across the country they're not
gonna roll that those out until the
summer and then as far as a health
health care workers who knows this is
really unacceptable the testing in
general has been a disaster but these
tests in particular are extraordinarily
important very important right
not-not-not three months from now not in
the summer and there's no excuse for
this lazy lackadaisical slow walked roll
out of the test because we need this
data right now we need the data to tell
us if this virus has already been here
for months like we just talked about and
if it has then as I just said the horses
left the barn which means the lockdowns
are useless worse than useless they're
they're not only financially but but
also in terms of health physical health
counterproductive because you're locking
people away who've already been exposed
we could very well be in a situation
that's a you know a young person who's
been exposed has been locked in
isolation now with their elderly parents
and because of that prolonged exposure
that's not broken up by you know going
out and doing things now the elderly
parents get infected otherwise they
might not have by the way the point is
if this thing has been spreading since
November and we start doing lock downs
in mid-march well then we will have
destroyed the economy for no reason in
fact this is anecdotal but I've heard
from many many many people who tell me
that you know in in the range of
November December January February they
came down with a pretty severe
respiratory illness many cases tested
negative for the flu and you know they
say it's like this is I never had
anything like this before it was very
strange I've heard this
it's a halt all anecdotal of course but
I've heard this from people all across
the country that have messaged me about
it and I was in the same boat you know I
had I had a pretty serious respiratory
illness in early February now I did test
positive for the flu so it's probably
likely that I just had the flu but there
were some things that were interesting
like for me I had and and the doctors
couldn't figure it out because I ended
up going to the hospital I wasn't
hospitalized so I went to the hospital I
got an IV and I talked to a number of
doctors and nurses between an urgent
care in the hospital they went to and
they couldn't figure out why about three
days before I came down with the flu I
had this rash that was that looked
really itchy but wasn't
and they did a bunch of blood work and
everything and they thought maybe was a
blood infection and it wasn't that blood
work came back fine they couldn't figure
what it was maybe it was an allergic
reaction well it turns out it wasn't
that and then I'm doing some reading
over the weekend and I find out that
there are some doctors who are saying
that coronavirus sometimes presents
itself first with a rash that proceeds
the more normal symptoms that were used
to hearing about so what does that mean
is I mean I don't know it's possible I
could have had both there are people
there are people who have these Co
infections where they get the flu and
and coronavirus all at once or corona
virus and some other illness on top of
it the point is who knows right it's it
but it is it is quite possible that
millions of us have already been exposed
to it have already had it
I've already recovered from it and
months or weeks after that we got locked
down in our houses and told we can't go
to our jobs okay let's go number two
well the corona virus models haven't
really been panning out too well but
here's one scientific model that I think
probably will reading now from the
mirror it says with the UK now in its
third week of lockdown many board Brits
have turned to gaming in the hopes of
filling their time stuck in house but a
new study looking into the effects of
gaming on the human body may put you off
gaming for a while
researchers from online casino dot CA
have predicted what avid gamers could
look like in just 20 years if they don't
change their habits the team has created
a model called Michael who doesn't look
too well and this is what now here's
Michael I'll show you the pictures what
they came up with and this is what
they're saying if you play games - video
games too much this isn't me okay I
didn't come out the researchers are
saying if you play video games too much
you might look like this in 20 years
basically you'll look like Gollum if
Gollum lived in his mom's basement
instead of a cave and if he had a BMI of
97 my only question is why are they
saying gamers will look like this in 20
years I think a lot of them sort of
already do no offense don't you know
don't take that as an insult I didn't
mean it that way personally I think
Michael's a pretty handsome guy that's
my personal opinion let's go to number 3
here's Joe Biden on ABC saying something
we cannot
let this we've never allowed any crisis
from the Civil War straight through to
the pandemic is 17 all the way around 16
we have never never let our democracy
sakes second fiddle way that we can both
have a democracy and elections and at
the same time correct the public health
we cannot let this we've never allowed
any crisis from the civil war straight
through to the pandemic of seventeen all
the way around sixteen we have never
never let our democracy sakes second
fiddle way they we can both have a
democracy and correct the public health
I have no idea what that I honestly
don't know what he's even trying to say
there that is gibberish and as
everybody's been saying this this is a
symptom of dementia it's not a joke this
this really is what you start to see
from people who are developing dementia
it's nonsensical
now look we've all stumbled over our
words I certainly have plenty of times I
do it all the time but to string
together a whole paragraph like that of
total nonsense
and when I say nonsense of meaning just
literal nonsense you can't you can't
make heads or tails of it it's almost
like someone took some words and just
put them in a blender and then poured
them out dump them on the table and this
is what it looks like right or if you if
you dump a scat a bag of Scrabble
letters on the tables like this is this
is what Joe Biden is offering now as
insight it's it's very concerning to say
the least number four the New York Times
used cell phone data to track the
movements of Americans and to report
which areas of the country are being
very disobedient and still driving a lot
you know instead of staying home and
they provided this handy handy map so
take a look at this the red areas are
where people are still driving about as
much as they did before the outbreak
happened but do you notice something all
the good boys and girls the people not
driving a lot who are obeying most of
them live in the metropolitan northeast
or on the west coast and the bad boys
and girls who are
naughty and are not listening and are
still driving a lot they live in the
south or the Midwest now what might
explain that well it could be that
urbanites are enlightened and
compassionate and very concerned for
with stopping the spread and helping
their fellow man I'm sure that's how the
New York Times would like us to
interpret this whereas the southerners
are a bunch of selfish Hicks who hate
science and the elderly and don't care
about anybody but themselves that that's
how we're supposed to interpret it but
it the other possible interpretation
here is that people in urban areas don't
have to drive to get to the grocery
store or the pharmacy or if they live
even in the suburbs not far from a city
probably there are retail outlets within
you know within a sixty second Drive of
them whereas enroll in rural areas the
basic necessities are far more spread
out which means that folks have to drive
in those areas if they want to go to the
grocery store or the pharmacy so that
could be what it is
but I think the bigger issue here is
that the New York Times has our
cellphone data and is tracking our
movements and then publishing the
information to shame us that to me is
the far more concerning aspect of this
number five dr. Burks on Friday warned
Americans that the next two weeks will
be really really bad where have I heard
that before I think I feel like I've
been saying that for the next for the
past five or six weeks and we need to be
super extra careful and she seems to now
be recommending precautions that go even
further than what we've been doing in
the past listen to this the next two
weeks are extraordinarily important and
that's why I think you've heard from dr.
Falchi from myself from the president
and the vice president that this is the
moment to do everything that you can on
the presidential guidelines this is the
moment to not be going to the grocery
store not going to the pharmacy but
doing everything you can to keep your
family and your friends safe and that
means everybody doing the six-feet
distancing washing your hands so yes
you're saying
don't go to the grocery store or the
pharmacy now what you kind of need that
you might need medicine you might need
to eat so now she's saying we shouldn't
even do that
it's total madness
speaking of which going on to our daily
cancellation Alexander occasion Cortez
moves into the prestigious position of
being the most cancelled person at least
on this show and I think probably
nationwide too she's probably the most
cancelled person and for good reason
this will be I believe her fourth third
or fourth cancellation and here's why
this one's happening check out the tweet
it says Kovac deaths are
disproportionately spiking in black and
brown communities why because the
chronic toll of red lining environmental
racism wealth gap etc are underlying
health conditions inequality is a
comorbidity kovat relief should be
drafted with a lens of reparations
so she's tying in reparations with
coronavirus relief a lot to unpack here
first of all what the hell is
environmental racism I've heard this
phrase many times from kooky left
wingers I still don't know what it is
and whatever it is I would argue that
white people are more often victims of
it for example you know I know I get
really bad sunburns when I go out in the
summer I could be outside for three and
a half seconds just in the time it takes
me to get from my house to my car I
could be burned to a crisp and whereas
people with darker skin aren't it aren't
as susceptible to that so to me that is
environmental racism that or maybe we
could call it solar racism that is the
Sun singling me out for being pasty
white and literally burning me almost
setting me on fire and burning me to
death in an act of cosmic prejudice so I
think at least I have I have a claim
also to being a victim of environmental
racism second the wealth gap is an
underlying health condition so now I
guess if you go to the doctor for a
physical and you run some blood work and
everything and then it comes back you
know
you might say well look everything looks
it looks okay you do have a slightly
elevated blood pressure we need to keep
your cholesterol in check and I'm afraid
to say you have wealth gap to use the
more medical term you're broke as a joke
just now so I can think of all kinds of
places that can go all kinds of
Orwellian possibilities for treating
being poor as an underlying health
condition but then third we get to this
thing where she's the whole idea of that
corona virus is affecting minority
minority communities based on any kind
of racism or whatever is obviously
absurd why is that actually happening
well it's not hard to figure out because
it's targeting cities it's not target
well it's not targeting cities it's just
that it's affecting cities more than
rural areas not because of the race the
respective races are the people that
live there but because of population
density so it's not about race Alex
angel Cortes it's about population
density and when you've got a lot of
people living on top of each other and
cramming themselves into Subway's and
everything you're gonna it's gonna
spread disease not just corona virus all
kinds of other diseases too whereas if
you live out in the country and you're
more spread out it's there's not as much
of a risk there so that's that's really
all there is to it and I could pretty
much guarantee you that any minorities
who live in rural areas which plenty do
they're gonna be in the same spot as the
white people who live in those same
areas okay now to move on to emails now
and doing things a little bit
differently this time I've gotten a
bunch of emails from people around the
country who've had experiences with
these state home orders and I just want
I want to read some of these I'm not
gonna read any names or anything but
just some of the experiences people have
had I think are worth worth looking at
so we'll start with this says hey Matt
in all honesty what the hell are we
supposed to do about the police stopping
us I was fishing in Stockton California
by myself with no one around me they
told me that I have to leave because
what I was doing wasn't essential I
responded by saying what is it that I'm
doing wrong no one is around me I'm not
sick they responded by telling me that
if I don't leave they will cite me with
a $500 fine another one says my
husband's uncle on his wife were stopped
by police for walking in an abandoned
shopping mall and again for walking
along an empty beach in Oregon another
one hi Matt I live in Long Island New
York and cops on horseback are ticketing
people walking in the street not far
enough
apart from each other most of them live
in the same house another one friend of
mine was surfing by himself in Pensacola
on Friday was approached by authorities
and told to go home
crazy how everybody is okay with this
another one my teenager was in her car
talking to other teens in their cars in
a parking lot and the police came and
broke it up threatening fines hey Matt
been following these citations too and
thought you might find it interesting
that the governor in Wisconsin has
ordered that all golf courses be closed
it makes no sense to me that people
wouldn't be able to golf especially
playing solo this got me thinking about
the essential versus non-essential tags
in some context I understand the need
for these but shouldn't we also be
categorizing things according to their
likelihood of spreading the virus just
because something is non-essential why
should it be banned if it doesn't
increase the spread here's one this one
isn't really about a law necessarily but
it is it is absurd I think says hi Matt
want to share my experience today I'm
from Venice California wife is 20 weeks
pregnant had and I've got I've actually
got a lot like this with this this exact
sort of situation is this is very common
apparently wife is 20 weeks pregnant had
to go for an ultrasound and they
wouldn't let me be with her and see my
baby's ultrasound due to Kovac concerns
they said no guess and I told them that
I'm the husband and father I wasn't a
guest and I had every right to be there
there was infuriating I even brought a
mask and gloves told them that if my
wife has it I probably have it too the
staff was very rude and told me I wasn't
even allowed to wait in the waiting room
had to go sit in my car and wait for her
there this was in an office not even a
hospital I couldn't see my boy in his 20
week ultrasound my first baby I feel
they robbed me of such an important
experience it sucks when will this
madness stop now my wife is worried they
won't allow me to be there for the
delivery
in a couple of months and I've heard of
cases like that too and makes absolutely
no sense whatsoever you live together so
you've already been exposed what would
if what if one of you has that the other
one probably does too or at least you
both been exposed to it already someone
else says I was fined $100 for smoking
crack outside a defunct Wendy's tyranny
is right around the corner you know what
if week if we can't even smoke crack at
Wendy's then what
just what's the point what's the point
of America anymore
this wasn't the cops but this is
different you know but someone going
along with the NHANES something going
along with the non-essential narrative
my friend was taking his kids for a walk
and he ran into his neighbor they
started talking while maintaining social
distance and someone driving by takes a
picture of them and says that she's
gonna call the cops he later finds out
that she posted the picture online on
the township police's Facebook page I
believe
luckily the police took my friend side
and said he wasn't doing anything wrong
which is surprising because we live in
one of the lockdown counties in
Pennsylvania if he lived in another
Township where the cops are more
overzealous he probably would have been
fined can you imagine that I thing is
the worst thing about this even putting
aside what politicians and bureaucrats
and law enforcement are doing to me I
would say at least the most discouraging
aspect is how many Americans are
treating each other and their neighbors
turning into snitches I just think it's
it's I could tell you I was at a park a
few days ago going for a run
which is an approved activity just so
you know why we have gotten the approval
to run where I live but I saw people
playing basketball and it appeared to be
a family just by the makeup of the
people very much appeared to be a family
playing basketball now I'm pretty sure
but 95% sure that basketball is now an
illicit activity you're not allowed to
do it it's it's considered non-essential
it's not now I'm not 100% sure and
that's part of the problem here it's
very vague but I saw that and what was I
do you think I called the cops
no because I would honest I would rather
be dead
than be the kind of person that would
call the cops on a family playing
basketball in a park minding their own
business not hurting anybody I it could
not ever be worth it to become that kind
of person
and the fact that so many people are not
just willing to be that kind of person
but are excited for the opportunity I
mean this woman in this story here she's
it sounds like she was just patrolling
the neighborhood it what if I was
driving along and I saw some people
walking around and they were you know
standing at a distance and talked to her
it wouldn't even occur to me in fact you
know what I would think I here's what I
would think to myself I would think well
that's nice that's great you know you
still got neighbors who are staying in
touch and everything and breaking up the
isolation a little bit respecting the
social distance that's what I would
think that's what a normal it's what you
would think right a normal person well
here you have this scumbag who sees this
and decides I'm gonna roll down my
window yell at them threaten to call the
cops and then and then take their
picture and post it online just
sociopathic behavior it's not just
politicians and bureaucrats and law
enforcement that are having a power trip
it's also your neighborhood snitch your
neighborhood snitch has is living in hog
heaven right now
she is is this is her dream come true
and I say she only because almost every
story I've heard like this it's almost
always a middle-aged white woman doing
it and I'm not saying that every
middle-aged white woman is a
neighborhood snitch but I think probably
95 percent of neighborhood snitches are
middle-aged white women I don't that's
how it works out I don't know why that's
the case maybe someone could do an
anthropological study on this I'm not
sure but that is how it works out okay
then I got a few emails from from police
officers who are very much not on board
with what's happening and I think these
are interesting so let me read a couple
of these it says I'm a cop in a small
town we've gotten many calls of paranoid
people snitching on kids playing
basketball or going fishing because we
have a few parts in town but luckily we
don't enforce any of those BS social
distancing rules
I'm sure it's worse in other places
though I agree 100% with their stance
that this whole thing is nonsense and
not right I'll sooner resign before I'd
ever take someone to jail for something
so stupid
I'm a police officer in a suburb of
Waukee Wisconsin we have lots of
busybodies calling in safer at home
violations if it's a personal residence
we're not even responding to the cat to
the call if it's a business we go to
verify its that it's open then leave the
decision up to the health department
most of us officers hate how this is
playing out and don't feel good about
having to possibly enforce any of this
and then says I'm a cop in Massachusetts
I would be pretty pissed if I was being
told to risk exposure to myself and by
extension my family by interacting with
people who aren't necessarily doing
anything that could spread the disease
it's bad enough that we have to risk
exposure answering regular Clause
fortunately my department hasn't told us
to enforce quarantine violations and I
can honestly say if they do I'll be
looking the other way and I've gotten
several other emails like this from
police officer let me just say these are
you know these are good police officers
and and and I think we also have to keep
in mind that you know it's it's not the
cops who decided on these laws they're
the ones that are just being forced to
enforce them and I would have to imagine
that a great number of them do not want
to because number one because they know
that they have to effectively harass
otherwise law-abiding good citizens for
doing normal things like fishing and I
think probably most police officers had
no interest in doing that but also like
like the the police officer in
Massachusetts points out they've got a
they have to risk exposing themselves
now so so this guy who's you know out
fishing or paddleboarding or whatever he
was not there was no risk of him of him
spreading the disease to anybody if he
had it but now because you're enforcing
the law now there is a risk whereas
before there wasn't and so we have to
remember that you know these a lot of
these police officers now I have heard
stories of people who've had these kind
of run-ins with cops who seem very
excited to be given this power and
authority but I think probably most are
not and certainly these here are not so
so I appreciate that I appreciate that
attitude and anyone else who has stories
like that I'm always interested in
reading them and calling attention to
them because I think that this I think
this stuff matters I think it does this
stuff should this just should not be
happening in America
and there's no disease that could ever
make it okay and we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening stay safe out there
god bless Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over the Andrew Kleber show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]